la France n'était pas à la raie hier et
je dis les syndicats ont raté leur coup
voilà et je dis aussi des Français se
sont couchés
bien sûr je pense vraiment que Monsieur
Macron il doit essayer de rassurer le
peuple comme il a fait
en rassurant il a été capable de
rassurer monsieur Mbappé sur un terrain
de foot il est pas capable
monsieur
Macron a été élu pour servir le peuple
pas pour le desserviro est en avant la
musique débarrassons ça bien proprement
le pays de la clique millionnaire j'ai
chaud ça c'est un ciel qui qui a été
fabriqué moi je sais parce que j'ai vécu
toute mon adolescence en Bretagne je
peux vous dire que je sais ce que c'est
un ciel nuag je sais comment ça se
fabrique etc
c'est un ciel qui a été fabriqué ils ont
épendu papa de particules
avec des particules
pour ces reconnaissable oh il est pas
content parce qu'elle s'est mélangé les
cartes Faller humoristes pour la météo
sincèrement c'est pas cool quelqu'un qui
a tripoté à mon application vous arrêtez
s'il vous plaît voilà donc c'est pas
grave je vais quand même vous dire ah
non mais ça me fâche c'est pas la
première fois et c'est très agaçant bref
nous avons une vigilance orange sur le
nord et le Pas-de-Calais je vous
explique c'est pour des chutes de neige
et je voulais juste un moment vous
emmener à la plage parce que c'est là
qu'il y a la neige en fait sur la plage
de Calais on en a dans le Nord ah nous
voici sur la plage de Calais alors à
moitié hein mais bon on va y arriver en
plus
vous avez vu la dernière comment dire
quelque chose et tout ça on a retrouvé
de la chair humaine dans les McDo c'est
à dire qu'en fait il se débarrasse de
tous les corps dont ils ont pas besoin
ça finit en bouillie chez McDo mais
arrêtez de manger n'importe quoi
on fait des bisous en plastique pourquoi
tu es rouge Dany essaie de me pécho par
contre faut pas le dire c'est ton chef
est dans le pré
si jamais vous avez un chagrin d'amour
ne demandez surtout pas cette enceinte
connectée de vous réconforter
le moral
vous avez fait de la prospection
téléphonique pour le RPR même une fois
fallait bien manger ah fallait bien
manger mais j'aurais pu le faire pour
n'importe quoi j'aurais pu faire pour
l'extrême gauche pour l'extrême droite
j'en avais rien à [__] fallait juste
que je gagne suffisamment d'argent pour
vivre en fait Pierrick assume deux bras
d'honneur à un député à l'Assemblée
nationale on attendait un geste du
gouvernement on en a eu deux et
franchement on peut penser ce qu'on veut
du bonhomme mais les bras d'honneur
c'est pas Damien Abad qui nous les
aurait fait voilà
c'était pas un bras d'honneur envers le
député et il a dit c'est un bras
d'honneur envers la présomption
d'innessence le ministre devait être
collé contre son siège comme ça il a dû
lui faire un truc du style
alors pardon il y en a deux il y en a
deux et les autres on lever le bras
monsieur Marleix et vous a fait un bras
d'honneur moi j'ai plutôt de la
sympathie en plus pour Eric
Dupont-Moretti mais là contrairement au
bras de Dupont-Moretti les bras montant
quoi le garde des sceaux qui fait un
bras d'honneur et qui dit ensuite non
non il y a pas il y en avait deux et
c'est comme ça maintenant que le
j'entends le démocratique non mais c'est
on a six à un suicide collectif quoi
direction le Sénat ou aujourd'hui et un
peu de magie direction le Sénat ou
certaines personnes sont partis à la
recherche de Mickey
[Musique]
et Thierry total puisque voilà voilà
vraiment là il y a de l'artisanat de
l'artisanat la pêche a été bonne une
fois de plus vous avez un lien avec mon
cul et je vais directement et j'en suis
fière mon grand-père a été maire de ce
petit village alors comment vous dites
mon cul ou mon cul mon cul mon cul on
dit mon cul qui a eu mon cul quoi et
donc il a été maire et la petite
anecdote supplémentaire c'est qu'il a
failli passer avec le histoire du Petit
Rapporteur avec Daniel Prévost
exactement il a pas pu parce qu'il est
parti avant et lors du tournage il y a
un poste vacant et c'était lui
normalement ah bon une nocturne qui a eu
raison des nerfs de Gérard Larcher je ne
sais pas si c'est dû à la coupure de
courant dans sa permanence qu'il a
obligé quand même mettre 10 kg de Sando
à la poubelle ainsi que cette tête de
veau et de jarret de porc
du froid toujours est-il qu'hier Gérard
Larcher était colère
en application
[Applaudissements]
Tudor dernier alinéa de l'article 44 bis
c'est moi qui préside aujourd'hui ma
grand-mère est toujours là-bas une
centenaire donc on peut dire que l'air
de Montcuq va préserve de toute manière
il y a zéro libido quand même quand il
vous filmes il recule un peu tellement
les odeurs sont désagréables il y a zéro
libido vous êtes crades c'est vrai ça et
le matin le cerveau fait vite un choix
sur la survie il y a plus rien qui monte
il y a plus rien qui vient
[Rires]
Alexandre il est drôle tu as pas bonne
idée
[Rires]
fête 14e saison de Pékin
exface ah d'accord le service RH chez
Twitter un peu de mal à suivre les
licenciements ah j'en veux pour preuve
ce message envoyé par un salarié de
Twitter Sherlock musk il y a 9 jours
l'accès à mon ordinateur a été coupé
ainsi qu'à 200 autres employés et il
voulait savoir comme votre responsable
des ressources humaines n'est pas en
mesure de confirmer si je suis un
employé ou non est-ce que je suis viré
ou pas alors et le meuf répond
[Musique]
salut est-ce que tu m'as fait là
[Rires]
bonjour Quel est votre poste
ils échangent et puis il explique le le
projet sur lequel il était s'appelle
Sigma réponse d'Elon musk mort de rire
sous-entendu tu es viré projet pourri tu
es viré et il explique le salarié
explique dans la foulée il reçoit un
mail après l'échange ça s'arrête là ça
s'arrête aux deux emoji mort de rire il
reçoit un mail après je change pour
apprendre qu'il est effectivement viré